and i know uh that has never happened
before in nba history no team has ever
recovered from a o2 deficit
to witness oh but they have oh but they
have
over and over and over and over and over
again so
look celtics and heat they played two
games they've been two close games
they've been games that the celtics have
had control of and both of them last
night
they were up big they were up 17 and
then the miami heat played a dirty trick
on them
they threw a high school zone out that
i'm sure brad stevens
has seen many times uh being from
indiana
the hoosier state so i'm sure he's seen
lots of zone defenses
but the celtics really struggled with it
miami heat give them props
they did a good job they were down 17
they kept playing hard they played
relentless
they got talent and and they're up 2-0
but
i'm not going to go crazy here mike like
you are you're so condescended you're so
quiet
give them props they played hard you
talk them you talk about them like
they're a cute little team like they're
not ten and one
i didn't say that playoffs i said no no
it's just it's just your tone
it's just the way you're talking about
him you sound like such a whole oh god
is just oozing through the screen look i
get you a reason for
optimism you're right they did lead in
both games
i get it i get that i get gordon hayward
maybe on his way back and i get we've
seen
teams come back from o2 deficits before
but i don't see it in this one just
because we've seen it happen before
doesn't mean that it's happening in this
particular eastern conference final
look yes they can come back doesn't mean
they will
bro you got to crawl before you walk
okay that's right
before they can talk about making a
comeback you got to be able to close
they can't close games so you got to
close out a game before you can talk
about
winning four of the next five games in
order to actually complete this comeback
i mean look yeah they can make it
interesting
but this heat team i think what's
happening and with what happened
what happened coming into the series and
what's continuing to happen
on the part of people like you who
clearly aren't paying attention
is the heat of just a nice little
scrappy you know
surprise underdog story that
upset the the the milwaukee bucks
and made the the mvp not a two-time mvp
and the bucks look bad so the story was
about the bucks
as opposed to it being about how good
the heat are and lo and behold
the the biggest of the celtics problems
might not
just this isn't the third quarter which
they cannot win a third quarter it's
also the miami heat and that zone
defenses try to clown just now
they would have they played zone more
than anybody else in the regular season
so brad stevens was so good at
adjustments i don't know where he would
have fixed it by now
see listen you need to stop throwing
other people's
arguments onto me i can make bad
arguments
i'm picking up your thank you bobby blue
bland i can do bad by myself look
man i didn't say they were a nice little
team i didn't say they were cute
team they've got talent i didn't say
that so you're saying
that that's what i said that's not what
i said but i think
a couple of things that are are that i'm
going to trip you up on right now i'm
just going to ask you point blank
let me ask you a point do you think the
celtics will win the game on saturday
uh you think that miami do you think the
celtics will beat them okay you don't
all right
all right so fine okay i didn't trip you
up because because uh because my point
is
yeah well because if you had said that i
was hoping you'd say yes
because you said if you think they can
win if you think they can win on
saturday
then it's a 2-1 series i could
understand if they were down 3-0
if they were down 3-0 i'd say all right
this thing is probably
over but i think you're getting caught
up in
the way they have they've stumbled down
the stretch and they've stumbled
throughout the playoffs so you're saying
they can't close the game
they stumble they stumbled against
philadelphia but we forgot about it
because philadelphia got swept
and we think philadelphia is a running
joke against toronto
they were a second literally one second
away from going up 3-0
then as i told you a four-foot dude
threw it over a 11 foot dude
and they that three zip that three zip
lead that commanding lead they're about
to have
and went to 2-1 they went to game seven
and they finally ended that series so in
this case they've been
this is a theme and maybe maybe mike
miami comes back
and makes them pay for their
their their propensity to kind of lose
focus during a game their propensity
to just lose their composure
respectfully respectfully
it's not respecting what you just said
what does
any of what you just said have to do
with the price of tea in china as they
say used to say or
that in 10 cents will get you a cup of
coffee okay none of that matters in this
series
i don't care what they did against
philadelphia or toronto all that matters
is they're here and now and if you want
to stop
you just said they can't close i'm just
trying to i'm just trying to get you to
show your work
okay i've been able to close these
struggles
they struggle to close how about that is
that right
why is it over
with your cute little caricature i see
your little lips first of all
first of all you said that
will they win game three i said no
i didn't say they couldn't win game
three so just so we're clear
i still of course they can win game
three of course they can come back from
2-0
it doesn't mean i believe that they will
we've seen teams come back from o2 i
repeat myself
i don't see it happening in this
instance but since you want to go math
and tell me logo if the celtics win then
you know then it's 2-1
i know how series works this ain't my
first rodeo and if you want to pull out
receipts
you're looking at you want to talk about
boston i am the guy
the guy who went on national television
some 15
16 years ago whatever it is now and
called the boston red sox
coming back from 3-0 against the yankees
okay check the teeth wherever so i know
how come that tape
network thing tony reality you talking
about i can call him up and ask him if
you know what we sound like right now
you know we saw
we sound like marcus smart and jaylen
brown sounded like in the locker room
last night okay
and here's the problem with this team
maybe they ought to do that at halftime
maybe they don't know they have time
maybe they ought to throw some stuff
around and have some furniture
moving and some hustle cussing and
fussing whatever they were doing post
game
do it at halftime instead of being the
avengers
be the preventers you know and actually
you know do it ahead you know get some
fire when you know you struggle with
third quarters they've lost what eight
out of nine third quarters or whatever
their number is
in these postseasons in the third
quarter 37 to 17 yeah
you know in this postseason 37 to 17 in
the third quarter i mean listen and it
came back and had an opportunity to lead
or they had to lean that opportunity to
win but jimmy butler
is not letting this team win or lose
excuse me he's not letting this miami
heat team lose
and he says something very interesting
at the end of his remarks last night
he said that the heat exactly said that
the celtics are the more talented team
than the heat
okay that's a mind game that's a mind
game he's playing within his own locker
room
while one locker room is struggling to
stay together
this locker room is saying hey we got to
keep that edge we got to play harder
because they're the more talented team
that's not even true
that's not even true but you see how
jimmy butler is leading meanwhile
the celtics are having late night
meetings okay they have a late night
meeting to discuss their emotions figure
out how to combat a 2-3 zone
okay yeah late night meetings to discuss
their emotions now
i just want to get you on the record
here all right first first i want to
hear some stuff i'm going to hear some i
want to hear them just like
talking about their issues and then i'm
going to come back and ask you a
question because i have some issues with
you
already
kevin with things getting kind of
emotional after the game what do you
kind of have to do
as a leader to make sure this doesn't
things don't go the wrong way and you
kind of keep everyone together and bring
everyone together it won't
and ain't nothing nothing happened in
the locker room i don't know what you're
talking about to be honest
you know we'll be fine it'll be fun
it's how it goes you know when families
is ups and downs there's fighters
emotions
um but that's exactly what we are family
and uh we're gonna
hold each other accountable and we gotta
do what it takes to come out
and execute that's again i mean what
happened after the game
what happens in the locker room we gotta
stay in the locker room uh
she's not supposed to come out here and
talk about you know what we talked about
as a team after a win or a loss
uh you know that's why we're going to
locker room and talk to each other
but whether we win we lose so i mean
that's
that's that both in both games we had
moments where we had lapses
and that team over there is together for
48 minutes
and we got to be together 48 minutes and
match that
i think that we've yet to do that i
think we're capable i think we need
every piece
every everybody to be all in and and to
continue to bring that energy
is what we're going to need but i think
this series is far from over
um i'm ready for game three i'm ready to
come out
um because you know that's what it's all
about
back against the ball ups downs and
fights regardless
see first of all you're a true pleasure
okay i'm gonna just call you out you're
a trip
don't try to you know i don't like what
you're doing i don't like what you don't
know what you're going through today
i'm just going to call you out don't try
to position me
as like some celtics homer just because
i got a book coming out on december 1st
on the celtics but about another era
another era of the celtics not these
celtics
big three big three paul pierce ray
allen um
yeah yeah and kevin garnett anyway kevin
garcia yeah got the other guy yeah
yeah yeah but no listen don't try to
i told you yesterday so if the celtics
had won this game
i wasn't going to overreact to it and
what i want to get you on the record
with this are you saying
that it's over because of what happened
in the locker room or is that separate
are you going basically that's
completely separate
okay completely separate yeah no that's
completely the second that's complete
this effort no i'm not i'm not i'm not
one of these people i'm not sitting
there saying they're imploding they're
coming apart i mean listen this show's
called brother from another
we have brotherly disagreements all the
time i'm not saying that that
yeah that's not that's not something
that alarms me listen
you've blown two late leads in the
eastern conference finals
you should be throwing furniture you
should be screaming
you should be arguing it's natural it's
sports
emotions should run high i am not basing
my analysis of this series
at all on what happened in the locker
room last night like water's wet teams
fight i don't care
i don't care up in the locker room on
the sideline i've never been one
to talk about oh my goodness oh oh my
they're fussing they're cussing
somebody's yelling i respect that
of course they are that's sports so i i
respect that
as a factor in not at all in my thinking
michael
and by the way just so people know
marcus smart is that dude everybody
knows somebody like that or maybe you
are that guy who's just like always
ready just to whisper away from a fight
like somebody somebody just kind of
raises an eyebrow and you're like oh
what's up
you don't even wait to say let's take it
outside you want to you want to handle
that business right now
that's marcus smart that's why he'll
never play mike he'll never play an 82
game season
either he'll do something on the court
like diving for a ball whatever one year
he missed some time because after a game
he was so frustrated he hit something
out in los angeles and broke his hand
he's just like an emotional
just emotional he's like he you can't be
he always fighting all the time you
can't hang around him like anthony mason
you